you voici une petite vidéo pour les un
an de la chaîne donc un an et une
semaine plus exactement parce que
annoncé la semaine dernière est gelée
lamentablement raté
donc voilà ça fait un an que de 0 19 ans
et voilà ça fait tout ce temps là qu'on
est ensemble
donc c'est cool et en plus on l'a passé
le cap des vingt mille abonnés que je
trouve énorme donc voilà ça me fait
vachement plaisir
je dirais même que c'est complètement
complètement dingos voilà c'est
complètement dingos du coup je te
proposait de me poser des questions sur
la page facebook et maintenant je vais
vous tuer je vais y répondre
voilà alors fils est-il un des multiples
de philippe en gros fils c'est bon
prénom
philippe non plus d'ailleurs c'est mon
prénom c'est si je le dis au début de
chaque vidéo jeux mais lio c'est cyrus
voilà et du coup ça ça m'énerve un petit
peu genre je reçois un message sur deux
salut fils banon une fois j'ai même il
ya même un mec qui marque mais dans la
rue et qui fait ouais c'est toi fils non
negras pas moins finie donc voilà fait
fixée pour philosophie c'est un jeu de
mots c'est pas un triple jeu de mot avec
mon mon prénom quoi voilà mais ça ça va
peut-être changer puisque le nom de la
chaîne risque d'évoluer puisqu'il n'y
aura pas que le coup de fil comme
concept que prévenu sur la chaîne pour
cette seconde année qui démarre voile
avec vous qu'on en parle il va y avoir
un dérivé du coup de fil mais version
psy donc avec des sujets non pas en mode
de goundam style comme une diversion psy
c'est des sujets de psychologie voilà
ensuite il va y avoir un clash de rap
entre deux philosophes
je vous sais pas encore qui c'est un
truc que je skie prévu depuis janvier
qui a été tourné et tout mais ça rend
pas très bien parce qu'on l'a fait a
cappella en mod rapporte enders
et là on a fait un truc des instrus et
où on va faire un truc avec des instrus
donc voilà il ya ça il ya peut-être
d'autres trucs que d'être surprise voilà
et il ya un autre format que je voudrais
faire plus fréquemment
c'est lié à une faq philo est bien là ce
serait je le reçois prendre une question
de philo et faire une petite vidéo
dessus
une question que du coup vous vous
poseriez soit faire un live et
transformer le live hanging out est en
gros le live devient une vidéo mais le
souk avec le live c'est que moi j'ai
jamais animé de l'aïe dit donc je sais
pas on va voir comment ça se passe et je
pense que tu as un essai on va voir ce
que ça donne
voilà pour l'année prochaine tout est
venue l'idée de faire des coups de fil
alors ça c'est une question qui revient
vraiment fréquemment bon les coups de
fil que la philo moi je vois ça comme un
peu une meuf très joli mais qui se met
pas en valeur devant alors toi qui tu
vas pas savoir s'habiller qui ce qu'il
ya une franche comté qui se cache
derrière ses cheveux ce qui est pas
maquillée qui doit c'est une meuf qui
veut pas séduire claire valeo pas
qu'elle ait l'impression à la batave et
manger quoi y'a pus la gueule toi et
parfois j'ai cette impression au sujet
de philo et alors que quand elle elle
veut plaire et des oufs la fio tu tombe
sous son charme
c'est sûr donc moi mon but ce que je me
suis dit c'est pourquoi ne pas rendre la
philo seksik parce qu'elle peut l'être
elle a le potentiel pour être sexy donc
barrandon la philo sexy du coup je suis
parti sur alors oui je faisais déjà des
vidéos des petits montages et cédera
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas en
refaire une chaîne youtube et je partis
sur un format très court très clair qui
pulse toi tu vas vraiment l'idée de
coups de fil
même si je m'appelle pas phil oakey et
doux l'humour aussi l'humour pour
contraster avec cet a priori vraiment
chiant de la philosophie même si ce
n'est pas un chien je précise
mais quand même un a priori à thème
cette image on ne peut pas le nier ou
pas le nier comment organise tout les
épisodes alors mon une fois que j'ai
choisi le sujet le sujet j'ai une liste
de sujets j'en prends 1
une fois que j'ai choisi j'ai créé un
script alors déjà je m'assure de bien
avoir compris donc je passe pas mal de
je lis beaucoup je me pose des questions
et cetera si je fais un script à
dominance à dominante par donc vraiment
philosophique avec quelques gars qui
seront venus une manière spontanée
ensuite une fois que j'ai ce script avec
ça coule et que j'ai un bon fils
conducteurs fil rouge
voilà une fois que j'ai ça et ben là je
vais ponctué je vais acheter des dégâts
pour rythmer un peu le truc excédera et
parce que même moi ça me fasse ça me
fait rire en suisse ce script l'agent je
le montre à 2 3 personnes
ils vont des retours je tourne je monte
je montre la version finale à si cette
personne qui me font des retours aussi
suivant les retours bas soit je choix
j'ai certains trucs que je modifie
complètement soit jean même je retourne
peut-être certaines scènes soient enfin
à voir
et ensuite je le balance donc voila
comme tu l'as vu les retours sont très
importants dans mon processus
- c'est vachement important que je m'en
fais pas seule dans ma perception et du
coup j'en profite pour remercier tous
ceux qui participent à ce retour la
merci tu fais souvent des références
cinématographiques dans tes vidéos
quel est le film que tu aime plus que
tout autre je pense alors tard le film
comique c'est facile c'est un endroit
magique voilà il est loin loin devant
beaucoup de films ensuite un film
préféré c'est très difficile comme
question parce qu'il ya plein de trucs
vraiment styles et genres soit cyrano
star wars matrix jurassic park
nintendogs moi je vais enfin ge qui tous
ces trucs là bas près au palais les
films un peu plus profond genre dit man
from earth mais c'est un truc qui n'a
pas quitté pas trop connu on mémento ou
ou des choses il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
fins beaucoup de films bien celui dans
quel tel je me retrouve enfin je me
retrouve le plus haut niveau de la
philosophie du personnage en tout cas
pas forcément je me retrouvais qui me
plaît c'est peut-être gladiateurs la
philosophie de maximus je la trouve
vraiment nikkei en fait il est reste aux
haïtiens finalement et et c'est une
philosophie que j'apprécie énormément
tu as des projets avec d'autres youtuber
nonobstant celui avec norman bah oui à
priori
après je peux pas t'en dire plus mais je
vais la japan expo j'ai rencontré pas
mal de vidéastes donc j'espère que de
fil en aiguille et des collaborations
qui vont se faire
est - ce sont ses mots sur mon kiff que
ce soit dans l'éducatif ou non m et oui
avec nous mêmes on a d'autres vidéos à
faire donc rester connecté quel est ton
parcours
alors non je n'ai pas fait de fac de
philo j'ai fait une prépa hec puis une
école de commerce et je me suis
spécialisée dans le webmarketing
notamment au niveau des campagnes ppc
pay per click
c'est par exemple les campagnes adwords
et c est donc juste avant mon échange
universitaire qui était dans une dans
une université au canada j'ai fait un an
j'étais un an chez ubisoft où je
m'occupais justement justement dans
cette partie là et c'était c'était
génial super boîte
alors je fais un petit coucou à tout le
monde parce que voilà on y est on est
potes et où tu vois c'est la famille tu
vois kemtuz dans la philo ou pourquoi la
philo
clôture c'est l'amour de la sagesse voix
pour moi ça n'a de donner les armes pour
comprendre le monde qui t'entoure et le
monde que toi tu entourent tu vois c'est
ce qui va te td a peut-être bâtir des
opinions prendre du recul sur certaines
choses améliorer peut-être même ta vie
tu vois là genre dans le truc de la
recherche du bonheur etc
tu vas te fixes et des idéaux tout et
même changer ton niveau de conscience
donc voilà ça t'apporte finalement
beaucoup de choses c'est j'adore cette
matière je trouve ça super intéressant
voilà et en plus en fin de soirée
quand tu parles d'une discussion philo
et à des fins de soirées magiques quoi
s'acheter gagner ta soirée quoi un petit
docteur vous alors il ya beaucoup de
gens qui en parlent mais je n'ai jamais
vu donc je ne peux pas te dire si j'aime
bien ou pas qu'est la console de jeux
vidéo avec laquelle tu as eue et
meilleurs souvenirs sans hésiter
nintendo gamecube notamment le jeu super
smash bros mais les genres tous les
mercredis après on y jouait les tout
jeunes gros fan enfin j'adore cette
console dans la vie courante parles-tu
philosophiquement non non non pas du
tout sauf si sauf si ça s'y prête
mais si tu veux pour moi tu as le monde
dépenser ou quand je dis le monde
dépense et c'est pas ces palmes en nous
tu va dépenser son argent
oh la la bref la tat le monde est pensée
ou genre à tutu a réfléchi à toutes les
idées et ces machins voilà état le monde
un peu la vraie vie tu vois le monde de
l'action et j'ai pas envie que le monde
dépense et entraves sur le monde de
l'action voilà donc donc non mais en
plus
enfin ça fait ça fait c'est chiant tu
vois c'est la plupart du temps ça c'est
parce qu'on sauf si le début est
évidemment le ca s'y prête donc sauf
s'il ya un cadre et que c'est haram et
sinon question un peu étrange
si tu devais associé de personnes était
un animal ce serait lequel
ben ça serait le poussin puisque c'est
celui qui a dû se poser le plus souvent
la question métaphysique de la poule ou
l'oeuf
est-ce que philosopher te fait peur bah
ouais par exemple le truc de ça peut
arriver
bah oui mais ça peut arriver parfois ce
que je vous disais sur le déterminisme
et le libre arbitre
voilà si je réalise dans le monde des
actions que je n'ai pas libre arbitre
bah ma vie elle est pourrie quoi je
prends aucune décision je fais juste
l'expression physique d'un truc
mathématiques
enfin de proba être deux actions
conséquence enfin le hockey me baritel
vachement limitée tu vois là plus
l'intérêt il est quand même et devient
vachement limité ta vie devient du coup
je trouve moins intéressante quoi donc
c'est un truc j'y pense mais je le
réalise pas ce que je m'en rends pas
compte
je refuse de me rendre compte dans ma
vraie vie ça que je sais pas vraiment
les ne tuera pas ce que j'ai pensé que
certains changements perception que je
vais avoir en pensant des trucs
philosophique impact ma vie ma vie là
réellement tu vois j'ai tu as vraiment
jeu j'essaie de au maximum se séparer
les deux pour continuer à avoir une vie
normale
comment ça se passait pendant des années
où tu as étudié la philosophie préféré
écouter réfléchir dans ton coin ont
confronté ton point de vue aux autres et
des points de rencontre spéciaux ou des
sites de discussion
alors l'idée c'est un peu des deux c'est
en gros tu écoutes tu réfléchis
d'entreprendre tu te fais ton unité tu
fais ton opinion et tu la confronte mais
n'ont jamais de jamais de
si de discussion de point de rencontre
spéciaux si ce n'est les cours en
eux-mêmes quoi participer
et voilà créer un dialogue continu
instaurer une sortie de vidéos
régulièrement
je ne dis pas plus fréquentes mais de
façon régulière oui oui je suis
conscient que c'était complètement
irréguliers cette année je vais voilà
lancé quand même conscient c'est en
grande partie à cause les échanges
universitaires
donc oui plus fréquents et enfin ou wii
régulier et même plus fréquents du coup
par rapport à ce que je vous ai dit sur
les projets et c'est pourquoi platon est
le cas alors je n'en ai aucune idée
il faut savoir que il est venu tout seul
un moment platon il est venu dans le
script et il voulait parler de kaka
cieux lors d'un script il ya des portes
qui s'ouvrent ya des personnages qui il
rentre et qui font un peu ce qu'ils
veulent
par exemple stéréotypes ça c'est le mec
avec la chaîne stéréo stéréotypes qui
était à la base et disait que des
stéréotypes mais bon c'est plus le cas
maintenant il fait que des blagues de
cul le personnage a dévié par exemple
dans l'année à bria n'était pas un
dernier coup de fil il est pas venu et
je veux pas le forcer c'est il vient où
il vient pas donc platon mais le caca il
est venu comme ça et après il ya eu des
retours négatifs sur le cas notamment
lors de l'épisode iv où je mettais en
relation le caca et enfin le fait de se
retenir de d'une diarrhée et l' angoisse
sartrienne et donc j'ai eu et j'ai eu de
gros retours négatifs sur le cacao et du
coup je pense que c'est un peu refroidi
place de kaka plateau enfin plateau et
le qui pourrait donc désolé cooper de
cartes mémoire carte mémoire plein voilà
je parle beaucoup trop
donc oui ça refroidit ça refroidit
platon kaka donc pas manquer kahn ne
vient plus après je fais peut-être
essayer de faire en sorte que platon
kaka reviennent voilà tu préfères la vie
ou la mort
c'est une question difficile je dirais
que je préfère la mort
d'accord mais d'abord qu'est on se
revoit dans deux semaines pour un
prochain épisode du coup de fil en ce
cas merci pour tous aux encouragements
je les lis tout ce qui tous les
commentaires c'est top d'ailleurs voir
les commentaires quand ça part en
discussion philosophique c'est vraiment
intéressant
donc voilà ça déchire n'oubliez pas
quand une vidéo vous plaît de la
partager c'est vraiment important pour
nous et youtube heures parce que ça qui
fait qu'il ya plus en plus de gens qui
vont ils vont nous suivre
voilà et on se retrouve en bande de
semaine et merci encore je vous envoie
du love et de la pisse ciao bella